liebe schon so ich war wohl im falschen
gebäude
das habe ich aber erst danach
herausgefunden es tut mir so leid können
wir uns nachher sehen 17 uhr an der
haltestelle lose straße sagt ja bitte
viele grüße ben ja
entschuldigung hallo
richtig an
dafür
hallo bento wer ist da ach hallo lena
hallodri wo bist du gerade
ach ich habe gerade nichts besonderes zu
tun sag mal wie wäre es denn wenn wir
uns gleich auf einen kaffee treffen oder
eine verwenden
das ist jetzt nicht so gut wieso ich
dachte du hast gerade nichts zu tun
nach lena ich war gerade auf wenn ich
hatte dir doch von ihm erzählt oder und
ich habe das gefühl als würde ich
umsonst warten
er hat mich versetzt
weißt du dass er kommt nicht genau das
meine ich er hat mich wohl versetzt ich
warte seit einer halben stunde auf bin
ich frage mich was da passiert ist
oh das tut mir sehr leid
aber was anderes ich wollte dich fragen
ob du am sonntag zu uns zum kaffee
kommen möchtest ich habe meiner mutter
von mir erzählt sie ist ein großer
brasilien fan und möchte mich unbedingt
kennenlernen hier gerne
na ja es wird wahrscheinlich ein
bisschen langweilig aber es gibt eine
echte deutsche kaffeetafel und ich
versetze ich auch ganz bestimmt nicht wo
bist du überhaupt am u bahn ausgang lose
straße in welchen es gibt mehrere